they
DRS same old same old longer t with a
slower flow sticking it in with no
lubricate just making us know that the
set the date who priz is up empir fall
simp Dragon Stout while I scratch my
balls be no seen or done before Mel pot
hot from a cold war ask him what is it
good for don't wake me up if I start to
snore train Killers kicking down the
door no shut to stop po we die some more
to blow n i them there waiting for the
bringing but I can't get in there and
welcome m to the terome not number 10
but nobody was home he was overseas on a
traic cruise they kill my dog and stole
my shoes dropping shells on my own
bedroom and overhead you can hear
my
again
again again
my
agains again
again they dring balls again call my
maning again
K look up to the bigger boys parents
turn down that [__] noise in the plet
sticker hate me like you looking at a
swat sticker not biggy not [__]
cannibal watch eat your face quicker you
can ball manang like a p of six but the
procaine pick up a p wher CL cocaine
this lior not going to take it you
twister sister you a No Name the lame is
quitter too much pain to pit spit aim
and hit you main Mr explain Slicker
creatures crazy who say the sicker got
bombs run up in the White House told
moms I'll be right
out man
B again
mying theying balls
again politicians reading lies right off
the Tonto they play runner on loose
sleeve no Indians or chiefs paper tiger
Jesus peace easy love is so fragile pull
the plugless laugh as they all down to
do the clouds the label L angels for
real slow it can take some time the
bombs blow blo and covered in jumps and
Li so fly never touch the ground
R my
man
again Dr again call my man and raise it
all again
all for